oh something just brushed past your
leg something
slimy
slithery something really really
big a giant squid has decided your its
next
meal how did a giant squid get the drop
on you are you going to be next on the
dinner
menu and how can your measly two arms
take on
eight this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were attacked by a
giant
[Music]
squid giant squids are one of the
ocean's most enduring Mysteries they
live in the deepest Waters of the ocean
and are rarely seen by humans in fact
most of the stuff we do know about them
is from dead carcasses that wash on to
shore
like its smaller relatives the giant
squid has two eyes a beak eight arms two
feeding tentacles and a siphon all stuff
you don't want swimming up against you
giant squids mostly eat deep water
fishes and other squids including going
fullon Hannibal Lecter and eating their
own
kind and they do not mess around in in
fact they're known to attack entire
schools of fish from below once they
grab a meal with the suckers on their
feeding tentacles they drag the prey
down to their sharp beak this cuts the
prey into more manageable pieces and as
if you weren't already too scared to
ever go swimming again they start doing
even more damage the giant squid then
uses its radula which is like a tongue
covered with teeth this slices and dices
the prey up into even tinier bite-sized
pieces dinner is served maybe you should
get out of the water like right
now if you're unlucky enough to be
hunted by a giant squid I've got some
bad news for you the giant Squid's sheer
size strength speed and hunting
abilities would make it extremely
difficult to
escape the first stealthy move it would
make is attacking you from
below o horrifying right well it gets
worse the giant squid probably isn't
going to devour you right then and there
it's going to drag you into deep water
where it feels safe from its own
Predators because it's so fast you would
definitely struggle with the changing
pressure and your eard drums would
certainly burst this Speedy Whiplash may
also break some of your bones from the
Giant squid holding you so
tight if you're somehow Not Dead by
being gripped and scraped by the feeding
tentacles the giant squid would use all
of its arms to bring you to its beak if
you're at this stage the hope of Escape
is pretty
non-existent the giant squid is using
all of its strength to pull you in for
dinner and I know it's a bad time to say
this but it won't be a quick death you
see giant squids have a bit of a gag
reflex problem so they're going to eat
you nice and
slow this is it you close your eyes and
prepare to be squid
food wait what's that sound a yeah your
buddy the sperm whale has come to the
rescue now giant squids don't have much
in the way of predators but sperm whales
yeah they stay away from those guys
researchers have found found giant squid
beaks in the stomachs of sperm whales
and battle wounds from giant suckers on
their bodies this means that your new
best friend has a taste for super sized
calamari the giant squid isn't going
down without a fight though and we go
toe to- Toe with the sperm whale now I
know it would be super cool to watch but
I think you're forgetting something
you're still
underwater if by some miracle you make
it back to land in one piece you're
going to have quite the story to tell
it's a shame no one will ever believe
you this is because giant squid
sightings let alone attacks are so
rare we still have so much to learn
about them there could be millions of
them lurking in the Deep Waters and we
wouldn't even
know they're the largest snakes on earth
roaming the Amazon they've eaten goats
deer and even
crocodiles so what would happen if an
anaconda tried to eat
you can an Anaconda really swallow a
human how long would you be traveling
through the snake's
body and has something like this
happened
before this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were swallowed by an
anaconda believe it or not in 2014
someone was actually dumb enough to
attempt this he was wearing a large
bulky suit covered in pigs blood the
Anaconda worked for an hour wrapping its
mouth around the head of the suit but it
was ultimately unsuccessful in
swallowing the human hole if it had been
successful how would an anaconda be able
to eat a full-sized
adult so you happen to be wandering in
the Amazon rainforest and you stumble
upon one of these giant
anacondas green anacondas grow up to 9 m
in length and can weigh as much as 225
kg you might think you'd be a tasty meal
to them as a small meal for an anaconda
is about 18 kg if they were to gobble
you up it would keep them satisfied for
weeks but a meal over 45 kg like you
might not be what an anaconda is most
interested in due to how massive you are
not to mention being taller and broader
than most animals it eats you would take
too long to consume this in turn would
leave the Anaconda vulnerable to
Predators for weeks if not months until
it finishes digesting
you but let's say it did want to eat you
what would happen then well before an
anaconda swallows you it would kill you
first an anaconda is a constrictor snake
and it kills by wrapping its body all
around its prey and quickly crushing
them to death with over 9,000 lb of
pressure it would be a pretty quick end
for you but we all know that's not how
this show works so let's assume you
survive this and we get to see the
entire process the Anaconda would then
widen its jaw to swallow you whole you
won't have to worry about it chewing you
up into little bits since it only has
fangs used for holding its prey and
luckily as opposed to other snakes the
Anaconda isn't venomous so its fangs
won't poison and paralyze you but
something you will find in the
anaconda's mouth is lots and lots of
saliva yeah this will be used to moisten
you you know so it's easier for the
Anaconda to slide you down their
gullet so now you're moving down the
snake's
esophagus as with many other animals the
muscles in the esophagus will push you
down the snake's body the Anaconda also
has the ability to move and bend Its
Ribs to crush you even further and push
you down into its
stomach okay now you're in the Anaconda
stomach don't worry we're still keeping
you alive you know to make this more fun
the Anaconda stomach produces powerful
acids and stomach enzymes that will
dissolve your skin and then eventually
your bones how fast do these acids work
exactly well an anaconda once dissolved
an alligator's skin in just 3 days so
your squishy fleshy skin would disappear
pretty quickly your body would break
down even further As you move through
the snake's small
intestine that's due to the liver and
pancreas secreting even stronger enzymes
everything besides your hair and your
nails would be digested at this point
and even if you were wearing some
magical suit that protected you from the
acid and everything else it would still
be a couple of weeks before you were
unceremoniously pooped out so it's
likely you'd starve although something
like this is incredibly unlikely just
leave anacondas alone after all they
aren't interested in eating you in most
cases as you're just too big they're
really just trying to defend themselves
plus you'd pretty much die instantly if
you tried to mess with one of these
things A giant fork tonged lizard with
razor sharp teeth and a bite with
bacteria laced Venom that's seeping into
your
flesh well this is no Legend it's a
Komodo
dragon what would happen if you were
attacked by one of these giant
lizards what would be your best bet to
fight it
off and if you escaped how long before
its venom would leave you in a pool of
blood
blood this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were attacked by a
Komodo
dragon Komodo dragons also known as
Komodo monitors are the largest lizards
in the world as adults they have an
almost uniform stone color and can weigh
around 70
kg the largest komodo dragon ever found
weighed 166 kg and and was more than 3 m
long they're powerful voracious eaters
with a taste for all kinds of meat from
small rodents up to a large water
buffalo their wide jaws and strong
throat muscles allow them to devour huge
chunks
rapidly and they can eat up to 80% of
their own body weight in one meal sadly
they are an endangered species with only
only
1,380 adult Komodo dragons left in the
wild they can be found in the Lesser
Sunda islands of Indonesia most fitting
the island of Komodo here they live on
beaches ridgetops and even tropical
Savannah forests just waiting for the
perfect chance to attack
you arriving on the island of Komodo
you'd be excited and looking forward to
some peaceful vacation time but as you
walk around the tropical forests you'd
be blissfully unaware that Komodo
dragons could already be stalking you
yeah their hunting strategy is all about
Stealth and power it comes down to their
sense of smell when they're on the prowl
for food and they can pick up the trail
of Rotting Flesh from up to 4 kilm away
for the Komodo it's not about taking a
whiff of air with their nose instead
their peculiar method involves sticking
out their long forked tongue to sample
the air then they roll it back in
touching it to the roof of their mouth
here the tongue rubs against a sensory
organ that can detect different Airborne
molecules a komodo can then use these
molecules as a guide for what direction
to head toward or it can stay perfectly
still for hours
just waiting for the prey in this case
it's
you luckily you'd spot the yellow tonged
lizard before it attacks now would be a
good time to run but with a komodo's
running speed clocking in at up to 20 km
an hour you wouldn't get very far the
dragon would bite down hard on your
ankle the pain would be immense but
you'd fight back you'd punch its neck
trying to force it to let go of you but
no luck maybe you'd better try prying
open its massive jaws with your own bare
hands you'd struggle and struggle but it
would work although it would come at a
cost your hands would get sliced by the
large serrated teeth of the Dragon now
you'd be bleeding profusely from the leg
and hands time to get away and find help
before the giant lizard has you for
lunch but a worse fate may now lay
before
you all over the commodo dragon's Jagged
teeth there are bits of meat from its
last meal those bits make the perfect
breeding ground for Dangerous strains of
bacteria and that bacteria would now be
infecting your body from your bite
wounds you could be exposed to 50
different varieties of bacteria some of
these are highly septic potentially
leading to severe
infection but the worst still wouldn't
be over you would now have venom
coursing through your body too this
would lower your blood pressure and
prevent your blood from clotting you
could only have a few minutes left
before you bleed out even if you slow
the bleeding this would be a terrible
way to go you could start to get the
chills and a fever your whole body would
be in pain eventually your heart and
circulatory system would begin to fail
entirely blood would no longer flow to
any of your organs causing them to
fail it's likely you wouldn't have the
time to make it somewhere safe and the
Komodo dragon hunt for you would
resume remember how they can smell
rotting meat from kilomet away well your
injuries would now attract every Komodo
dragon around you and while no kodo
dragon could swallow you whole on its
own a group of them would devour every
scrap of your
body yeah that's right they'd eat your
bones and your
intestines possibly even swinging them
around a bit to remove all the
undigested contents oh what a delicious
meal
as scary and horrible as all this would
be you could rest a bit easier knowing
that it's extremely rare it happens sure
but prior to a deadly kodo dragon attack
on a young child in 2007 there hadn't
been a single fatal incident on Komodo
Island in 33
[Music]
years hip bows are large loud and
dangerous they kill 500 people a year in
Africa and their attacks are
vicious so if you're around one keep
your guard up and don't be fooled by its
big cute face well look at this little
fell that hippo might be
hungry but do hippos eat
meat what warning sign should you watch
for and could a hippo fit your whole
body in its
mouth this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were swallowed by a
hippo these water-loving creatures can
grow up to 5 m long and they weigh up to
4500 kg it takes a lot of energy to
carry all that mass around so these
Hungry Hippos have to eat 35 kg of food
every
night luckily they're
herbivores for the most part there have
been reports of hippos eating carryon
but they're rare humans are definitely
not in their diet but that doesn't mean
you can relax around hippos they're
incredibly aggressive and there's one
warning sign that you should never
ignore if you see a hippo open its mouth
in a yawn or a laugh you're in trouble
this is a sign that it's going to
attack you think I'm going to tell you
to run sorry but hippos can charge at up
to 30
kmph and sometimes there's no warning at
all hippos will often Glide underneath a
small boat flipping it and throwing its
passengers into the water once you're in
the water your chances of surviving are
slim but could a hippo swallow you
whole while they are big animals a hippo
wouldn't be able to consume you in one
bite instead you'd feel intense pressure
as the hippo begins to crush your arms
or legs with its
teeth you punch the hippo right in the
nose and it loosens it grip on your body
but although you managed to break free
you're in bad shape there are huge holes
in your side from its tusks parts of
your body are unrecognizable and you're
missing an arm yeah that arm is still in
the hippo's
mouth now while you're being rushed to
the nearest hospital what happens to
your missing
limb hippos have a unique digestive
system they have three stomach Chambers
and they use a method called forut
fermentation microbacteria living in
hippo stomachs break down food early in
the digestion process it's a symbiotic
relationship that allows hippos to get
the most nutrients out of tough
grasses so after your arm travels down
the hippo's throat and goes into the
first chamber of its stomach
microbacteria would begin to break down
on your
arm then your arm would pass onto the
true stomach this is where digestive
enzymes would continue to break it
down later the hippo would fling
remnants of your arm and some grass over
the beast's territory hippos can spread
their feces up to 10 met around them
this plays an important role in the
rivers and lakes of Africa by eating and
EXP exing grass hippos add silicon into
Africa's water systems and that's good
because unicellular algae needs silicon
to thrive the algae produce oxygen and
it's a key part of the food
web hippos are extremely Territorial and
they're obsessive about protecting their
young so while baby hippos sure are cute
you should always steer clear of them
most attacks happen because mother
hippos see humans as a threat to their
offspring beware after many millions of
years the T-Rex is back and this giant
scary Predator is setting its hungry
sights on
you what would running into this
dinosaur be
like how could you Poss possibly
escape and what would happen if it sunk
its teeth into
you this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were attacked by a
T-Rex during the late Cretaceous Period
about 66 million years ago the T-Rex was
one of the largest known meat eating
dinosaurs its full name Tyrannosaurus re
means king of the Tyrant lizards and it
certainly fits the profile these
dinosaurs towered at up to 6 M tall with
the strongest bite of any land animal
that ever lived the T-Rex was a
ferocious
Predator back in its day it was roaming
the once Lush and warm western parts of
the United States but somehow it's back
and it's on the hunt for you
run your peaceful walk in the park would
take a turn for the worst you'd look up
and suddenly see the frightening sight
of a T-Rex Rising above you Frozen with
fear you'd quickly take in its
terrifying features its powerful tail
counterbalancing a massive skull it's
thick neck muscles and it's muscular
thighs that would be a good reminder
that you shouldn't have skipped your leg
day at the
gym though I wouldn't advise it you
might involuntarily chuckle at the sight
of the dinosaur's puny two fingered
forearms but your amusement wouldn't
last long the T-Rex would flash its
gigantic teeth at you some of those
could be 30 cm long as a fan of the
Jurassic Park film franchise you might
think that the best thing to do is
remain standing as still as possible but
research suggests that the T-Rex had a
sense of vision as good or better than
modern-day
Eagles yeah now would be a good time to
run another thing Jurassic Park LED you
to believe is that in order to get away
from this Predator you'd need to be able
to move as fast as a car well that would
mean running at a speed of 50 km per
hour and that's impossible for
humans yeah even the world's fastest
person usin bolt with his top speed of
44 kmph wouldn't make it out
alive but you'd still have a chance
today scientists debate whether or not
the T-Rex could run at all research
supporting the theory that the dyo could
run estimates that this Predator would
be able to move at a moderate pace of
about 25 5 to 40
kmph any faster and it would break its
legs on the other hand the T-Rex might
not have been able to run at all instead
it would have walked at a slower than
human pace of 5 km per hour that's about
as fast as a soft shell turtle knowing
this you could jog a comfortable
distance from the attacking T-Rex and if
you're not a runner soon enough you'd
stop to catch a breath but that would be
a mistake your moment of relaxation
would suddenly be interrupted by
extremely sharp
pain yeah another T-Rex has found you
with its amazing sense of smell and it
would sink its teeth into you with that
sharp pain you'd feel your bones being
crushed the T-Rex would be using its
so-called puncture and pull strategy on
you the dinosaur would drag its teeth
right through your Flesh and Bones this
would be a gruesome way to
die its front teeth would grip and pull
you to shreds while its side teeth tear
your flesh from your body its back teeth
would be moving your body closer and
closer to the T-Rex's throat struggling
to break free wouldn't help you now your
attacker's wide teeth wouldn't break
from your wiggling after all this Dino
used to hunt
triceratops and to make things worse the
dinosaur's powerful neck muscles would
thrash you around these muscles would be
strong enough to throw a 50 kg chunk of
meat about 5 m into the air hey sorry to
be so gruesome but what did you think
running into a prehistoric creature like
this would be
like something is lurking in the water
do you see it
close calls like this happen with whales
more often than you might expect and
although the people in these videos Got
Away relatively
unscathed there's no denying that they
were just meters away from being a
whales
lunch but what would happen if they
hadn't been so
lucky could a human body survive being
swallowed by a
whale has it ever happened
before this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were swallowed by a
whale if you've never seen a whale up
close it's hard to comprehend just how
monstrous they can really be to put it
in perspective the blue whale is the
largest animal on the
planet its tongue alone weighs as much
as an elephant and it can fit anywhere
between 400 and 500 people in its mouth
but we wouldn't have to worry about one
of these guys swallowing us anytime soon
because their Anatomy makes it nearly
impossible instead we should be more
concerned with their smaller cousins
sperm whales in
1891 reports emerged that a man had been
swallowed by one of these whales and
although he lived to tell the tale he
would never be the same
again according to the story James
Bartley was swallowed when a whale
attacked his ship and he wasn't
retrieved until the following day when
the crew found and killed the whale they
quickly brought it on board their ship
and cut it open revealing an unconscious
but very alive James Bartley his face
and arms were bleached white and he was
blind all thanks to the stomach acids of
the
whale however as the years went by
people started poking holes in this
story and questioned whether James had
really been swallowed by a whale I mean
wouldn't the stomach acids do more
damage than just bleaching his skin well
with the power of science we took a
closer look and we quickly discovered
that if you get swallowed by a whale
coming back out with shiny white skin
would be the least of your
worries okay so the first thing you'd
have to worry about once you were
swallowed would be get shredded to
Pieces by the sperm whale's impressive
set of teeth each tooth is approximately
20 cm long that's about the length of an
average chef knife and whales have
anywhere from 40 to 50 of these let's
say you're lucky enough to make it past
all of them next you'd begin your
descent down the throat Not only would
it be dark and slimy down here but you'd
also find it hard to breathe due to the
lack of oxygen and an increase in
methane gas
as the whale's throat muscles
constricted in and out to help Force you
down you'd also start to feel
hydrochloric acid beginning to eat away
at your skin I know what you're thinking
we just got into this whale and James
Bartley's story already seems pretty
fishy well you're not wrong but what
would be the fun in stopping
now so next you'd be dropped into the
first and largest of the whales four
stomachs you'd probably be in there for
a while but on the bright side you might
have some light in the form of a
bioluminescent squid or two being noshed
on after your arrival sperm oils love
neon flying
squid you'd better enjoy this brief
light show because after this you'd just
be tossed from one stomach to the next
with the acids breaking down almost all
of your body until you're just a bunch
of Bones being unceremoniously ejected
from the whales
anus so yeah it's pretty safe to say
that there's no way you could be
swallowed whole by a whale and live to
tell the
tale sorry James you may have been able
to fool people in the 1890s but we're on
to you now as vast as they are and as
monstrous as they might seem to us
whales actually have no interest in
eating humans and if they could talk
they would probably make a point of
telling us
[Music]
that ah it's a beautiful day for a hike
in the woods there's nothing but the
fresh air trees and killer
bears oh
my what would it be like to meet up with
a
bear in what ways would different kinds
of bears
attack and what could you do to stay
alive this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were attacked by a
bear close encounters with bears don't
always lead to them attacking you there
are only about 40 bear attacks around
the world every year give or take but if
you do get attacked you're in big
trouble and each type of bear could have
a different dinner plan for you you
could run into a 58 kg female black bear
or a
315 kg grizzly bear with her Cubs or if
you're in the Arctic you might face a
vicious
590 kg polar bear
whoa staring up at the gaping jaws of
any bear could be the last thing you see
will your next move save your life
after a peaceful night of camping you
unzip your tent and find you've made a
big mistake you've left some food out
and now you've been graced with the
presence of a dangerous visitor it's a
black bear you gasp and freeze in place
but don't worry yet black bears usually
don't attack in a sudden encounter
mostly they attack in self-defense so
don't get too close you slowly step out
of the tent and Scoot a few steps back
to give the bear some space but you're
not far enough away now the bear is
showing aggression with some grunts you
could run but then you'd have to leave
all your stuff behind instead you spot a
nearby tree and think I could climb that
and' be safe well as you dash toward the
tree the bear is right behind you
luckily you were closest to the tree
with running speeds up to 40 km an hour
black bears are fast you scramble up a
few branches and look down to see the
bear climbing too yeah black bears can
climb so now you'd be screwed when it's
close enough to attack the black bear
swipes its massive claws at you a black
bear's claw claws are good for climbing
but they aren't that sharp so it's the
Bear's strength you'd worry about black
bears can move Boulders weighing 140 kg
with one paw and one swipe from this
bear knocks you down to the ground ouch
your surging adrenaline helps you spring
up while the bear is still in the tree
it's time to make a run for it you'd
Sprint down the trail until you couldn't
run run anymore you'd need to stop and
catch your
breath but what's that Dreadful
crunching
sound turning around slowly you
freeze oh no it's a grizzly bear with
two
Cubs the mama bear begins rubbing her
body on a nearby tree is she just
scratching an itch H not quite she lets
out a loud growl you realize that you've
surprised her and she's being aggressive
to protect her Cubs but you wouldn't
have much time to react this
opportunistic Hunter charges toward you
at a blazing 64
kmph you make a quick evasive move but
the bear swings one of its claws at you
a Grizzly's claws aren't razor sharp
since the bear uses them to dig but they
are strong and one hit knocks you down
hard the grizzly is on top of you and
its body weight keeps you pinned its
massive Jaws are about to clamp down on
you with a force of
8,274
kilopascals you think you're done for
and you might be right the best thing
you could do now is to play dead
it's a terrifying gamble but it would be
your best shot at surviving the bear
would Sniff and slobber all over you
each movement of its paws digging deeper
into your body but it works Mama Grizzly
walks back over to her Cubs and you are
completely motionless until you hear the
Bears crawling off into the distance
phew you scrambled to your feet and run
back to your
car finally you're safe you
survived not so fast there's one more
type of bear to worry about and it has
been stalking and hunting you for prey
it's a male polar bear wait
what a polar bear follows its prey using
its exceptional sense of smell
so now you won't be able to hide and you
left your car key with the rest of your
gear at the campsite after a day of bear
attacks this would be the end of the
line one swipe from the Bear's 9 and 1/2
CM claws can snap your
spine then it would Feast on
you as your life drains out of you it
you'd suddenly realize something polar
bears are supposed to roam the icy polar
deserts in the Arctic
Circle that's definitely not where you
went camping as you snap out of this
traumatic
fantasy you have to face reality as a
pair of day hikers step out of their car
and find you in your dirty
[Music]
pajamas
you might want to stay on the boat this
part of the ocean doesn't belong to you
it belongs to this Beast the Atlantic
Goliath
grouper and if you wander too close to
these Shadows you may not come back out
so what would happen if this giant
devoured
you what part of you would the fish eat
first could you outswim this predator or
would you have to escape out its other
end yeah that
end this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were swallowed by a
grouper reaching weights of up to 360 kg
and lengths of almost 2 and2 m the
Atlantic Goliath grouper fish stalks its
prey from the depths of the Atlantic
Ocean this massive fish can take down
small sharks and even an occasional
human their lack of fear has allowed
humans to get close to them and hunt
them to dangerously low levels with
their numbers down by
80% the Atlantic Goliath grouper is a
critically endangered species plus its
slow speed makes it an easy target so
how could a fish this slow catch
you an opportunistic Predator the
Goliath grouper can spend hours in dark
holes waiting for the right moment to
eat everything in its path this type of
grouper lures large fish and
invertebrates by just opening its mouth
and if you linger for too long in one
area
this Predator could eat you alive its
mouth opening is so huge that the
negative pressure it exerts sucks
everything in its vicinity inside the
grouper mouth but what would this rapid
change in pressure due to your
body the inside of your body builds up
nitrogen gas when you swim deep
underwater when you're near the surface
your body can expel the gas quickly but
when you've been down deep you need to
ascend slowly and give your tissue time
to let the gas out
naturally when your body under goes a
sudden shift in pressure the excess
nitrogen in your body could expand and
form bubbles in your bloodstream if the
negative pressure was too intense it
could give you a stroke or even paralyze
you on the spot but could you get away
from this fish it's not that fast right
well you might be able to outswim this
Goliath but you would also have to
survive its tremendous Sonic
Blast this Beast might contract the
muscles around its swim bladder and
release a shock wave that would stun you
so you'd need to keep moving but if this
monster came at you full speed it would
have its mouth open sucking in the water
water and everything around it and while
this grouper could have up to five rows
of pointed teeth they aren't for chewing
they're for keeping you inside and
moving you further into its hungry mouth
unless you have an oxygen tank uh you
will drown inside this cavity water
would fill your lungs and with your air
cut off you would experience severe
brain damage but if you had some way to
breathe in here this horrific Journey
wouldn't end in the Goliath's
mouth from this enormous Cavern you
would travel down the fish's esophagus
into its stomach and there you might
meet an even worse end like being stuck
in a washing machine the fish's stomach
would churn and grind you while coating
you with its digestive
enzymes unfortunately this massive
muscular organ evolved to hold large
prey just like you but don't worry you
only have one stop left although I don't
think you're going to like it no God if
you think you could Escape out the uh
back door of this fish think again the
pyloris the sphincter muscle prevents
any waste from getting through until the
fish is ready yeah you would have to
wait until until the fish expels its
waste before you could think about
swimming away if your body somehow
survived to this attack your mind would
be disoriented and scared you would need
to control your breathing and watch the
direction of your exhalation bubbles
follow them up to the surface and
remember go slowly after everything
you've been through the last thing you
need is the
bends an encounter with an Atlantic
goliath grouper could leave you stunned
drowned or even dead and even if you
escaped you would be alone in the cold
Dark Water and you'd be even more
vulnerable they've been terrorizing
animals and humans in Asia and now
they've come to North
America this is the murder Hornet one of
the deadliest insects on our planet
what would happen if a murder Hornet
stung
you could you be killed by
one and what makes them so
deadly this is what if and here's what
would happen if you were attacked by
murder
Hornets hornets and wasps in general are
deadly in the United States they cause
33% of animal related deaths in adults
but Asian giant hornets or murder
Hornets as they're now known aren't just
your average insect they're extremely
fast flying up to 40
kmph they're the largest hornet in the
world and they destroy entire bee
colonies with
ease so we know they're lethal to bees
but what if a murder Hornet stung
you if a pack of murder Hornets is about
to sting you you'll first hear a loud
buzzing
noise what's different about these
Hornets compared to others is that they
might be lurking
underground so there's a chance they
could sneak up on you and you wouldn't
see them
coming if this is about to happen run
away as fast as you
can experts say you definitely don't
want to swat
them so you'd try your best to cover
your face and to seek shelter as soon as
possible but what if you didn't manage
to get away in
time just one Sting from a murder Hornet
could cause some severe issues the pain
of their stings has been compared to a
hot nail being jammed under your
skin that's from their long stingers
which are extremely painful when touched
but the main thing you'd need to worry
about is the neurotoxin they inject into
your
body it's called Mander Toxin and will
destroy your red blood cells once you're
stung not only that but the toxins are
strong enough that they could also
dissolve your
skin the pain from just one sting could
be so severe that there's a good chance
you'd collapse on the
ground you could try your best to run
away but you'd probably be in too much
pain you might instinctively try to swat
them away but that would only attract
more of them towards you and make them
more
aggressive and if you did manage to run
and hide in water that may help as they
wouldn't sting you while you're in there
but they'd wait for you to get out and
attack you again now these Hornets are
psychopaths and if you don't manage to
get away before you know it you'd be
surrounded by hundreds of murder Hornets
ready to sting
you they'd all begin to attack and it
would feel like hundreds of Sharp hot
Nails being jammed in your skin your
body would start to swell and balloon up
with each sting it would be harder to
move and in just a couple of minutes
you'd become unconscious from the pain
the Mander toxin would then enter your
bloodstream shut down your organs and
kill
you and because the murder Hornets are
even bigger jerks than we thought they'd
continue to sting you even after you die
until they no longer deem you a
threat but you can avoid all this after
all the murder Hornets attacked you
because they thought of you as a threat
so if you can try not to go near these
things and then you should be
okay but what if we couldn't avoid them
because all of Earth's insects were
giants well we'll leave that story for
another what
if
imagine you're out for a blissful swim
trying to catch a glimpse of some
beautiful whales the sun is shining the
water feels refreshing and uh-oh
something